now the problem when you are trying to do this when you're trying to
estimate
and guess
Something right? Because again what's statistics in many
cases? We won't have or we won't have
all the data we need so we have to guess.
What that data will be?
our big obstacle we uncertainty
How can we be certain that what we're looking at or what we are guessing is accurate.
this is where
Can anyone guess?
probability here comes in.
so test statistics
is this
this is science.
Of trying to figure things out about populations and
samples.
But you have one weakness. You have a major flaw in what you
in we have a big problem when you're trying to
do this and that's uncertainty this is where probabilities here comes in. It's the
science of uncertainty.
techniques for figuring out
or dealing with risk and uncertainty and
chance.
and measuring
House and did to help you determine how
certain you can be. This is where probably Theory comes in.
And that's why these two are often paired together. And in fact,
they share a lot of
mathematical Concepts
okay, so this was a motivating reason for you to
want to learn the
the concepts the mathematical notation
of these two fields in Greater detail
Okay.
Now where does our fit in the picture what are allows
us to?
Employ the power of computers and
especially computer programming.
to
make it easier for us to solve.
until you know
solve the mathematical problems because the mathematics can be quite
what do you call it?
time consuming
If you have to do it by hand, and so that's where R. The
programmers are comes into comes into play.